Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, yesterday in
my Episode 6 video I asked you all to submit
your biggest questions so I picked 10 of them
to answer in this video with one bonus question.
I think we were all in agreement that Peter
Dinklage was the high point.
And Shae being the low point.
First thing’s first, congrats to Storm Ragnerok.
You’re this week’s winner of the giveaway.
You win a $20 amazon gift card.
I’ll be messaging you on your channel for
details.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I’m doing a weekly giveaway along with
my game of thrones episode reviews, just as
a way to say thank you to all you guys for
being so awesome.
I’ve also got some special links down in
the description for my schedule this week.
There’s a lot of really big stuff coming.
Be sure to subscribe to get it all.
And let me know if you want me to keep posting
a master schedule each week.
Time to answer some questions!
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Question 1 - The Swedish Dude asks Do you
think we’ll be learning more about the other
important people in Meereen soon?
Since we saw Hizdahr in episode 6 I think
there’s a really good chance we’ll learn
more about the other important people around
Meereen.
Daenerys hasn’t gotten any super long scenes
in the last couple of episodes, so she’s
due for something big soon.
Most of the focus right now is around Tyrion’s
Trial, so after that passes I think we’ll
get at least one long Meereen episode before
the finale.
The show has this weird thing where it likes
to end on really strong Daenerys moments.
With the exception of Season 2, which was
that White Walker.
That doesn’t guarantee season 4 will end
on a Daenerys moment.
But I do think it would be funny if there
was a meta thing going on where each season’s
end rotated between Fire and Ice.
Fire being Daenerys and Ice being stuff going
on up at the Wall.
I guess the show has been doing that so far.
So technically that would mean this season
would have to end on another scene up in the
North.
Start your theorycrafting now.
Question 2 - Starlight (no avatar) asks what
was Varys motivation to testify against Tyrion
if they were friends?
The interesting thing about Varys is that
he and Tyrion are on the same side.
They both want to do what’s best for King’s
Landing.
But I think Varys testified against him because
he felt it was more important to his long
term goals of strengthening the realm.
Than the short term goal of rescuing Tyrion.
Varys is totally willing to throw people under
the bus if it helps keep his plans on course.
That’s why he’s just as dangerous as Littlefinger.
Varys just has more noble goals.
He’s not trying to win the throne for himself.
I saw a lot of confusion in the comments after
the episode.
Because he looked at the throne when he was
talking to Oberyn.
The throne is just a metaphor for his plan.
He doesn’t actually want to be King himself.
The really important thing he said was he
never forgets anything.
He still cares about Tyrion, it’s just that
testifying was the best course of action at
the time.
Speaking out against Cersei at would have
thrown all his plans into chaos.
Question 3 - Adam Thomas asks WTF Shae?
Yeah, this was one of the biggest fist shaking
moments everyone had.
Let’s forget about the books for a second
and just think about what her character has
been doing on the show.
I saw two things going on, first she did look
like she was trying to hurt Tyrion.
She was intentionally testifying.
No one was holding a sword to her throat.
But Two, it also looked like Cersei had some
involvement.
Shae kept glancing in her direction when she
was testifying.
Remember, Cersei’s maid listened to Shae
and Tyrion arguing and we never saw her follow
up with Cersei.
So it’s possible that Cersei found out something
was going on and offered Shae money or something
else in return for her testimony.
That being said, I think she still loves Tyrion.
She’s just really headstrong and doesn’t
care at all about the other politics going
on in King’s Landing.
Tyrion has been in this really awkward place
politically, all season.
Having to deal with Sansa and avoid getting
murdered at every moment.
He’s been walking on eggshells all season.
And Shae doesn’t care about any of that.
I don’t think she fully realizes what’s
going to happen if Tyrion is convicted.
So if you want to blame her for something,
blame her for ignorance of all the politics
involved in what’s going on.
Question 4 - Cassie Pryor asks Do you think
we’ll see any of the other Greyjoy Uncles
this season?
There haven’t been a lot of Greyjoy people
this season.
And they didn’t announce any new castings
for them so the chances are pretty slim.
The Moat Cailin Ramsay Snow plot deals with
the Ironborn, so it’s possible they could
be involved.
But the producers and HBO haven’t made any
announcements.
So it’s unlikely.
If you’re not familiar with all the Greyjoys,
there are a lot of secondary characters that
get mentioned.
But the show has a habit of cutting characters
out and giving their lines to other characters.
Like with the Brave Companions or Strong Belwas.
Question 5 - Lenny asks When will they start
casting Season 5?
Usually we start to hear casting news during
the summer.
So plan to hear a few things around Comic
Con in July.
They don’t cast everyone at once either.
So they’ll be announcing new people all
the way into the fall.
They have started scouting locations, which
is one of the first things they do before
they cast people and start preparing new episodes.
First they have to find out where things are
going to be filmed.
A lot of you have been asking me about Dorne,
I can’t confirm we’ll see Dorne next year.
But when they announce the new shooting locations
we’ll get a pretty good idea.
Usually those don’t stay secret.
So if they end up filming near a desert we’ll
have our answer.
Question 6 - BDDestro asks What would happen
if Daenerys always let her dragons roam free
and didn’t keep them caged up?
And are they evil or just playful?
Based on the literature inside the show, Dragons
will just keep growing if they have enough
food and space.
If you confine them, they won’t grow as
much.
So if Daenerys just let them roam free and
live out in the open, potentially they’d
get as big as Balerion the Black Dread.
Here’s a picture for scale.
The problem with that is that they’d need
a massive food supply, so they’d have to
eat everything in sight.
And they are playful but because they’re
deadly wild animals, when they do play, they
can tear things to shreds.
Or incinerate them.
There’s always stories about people raising
wild animals like tigers or alligators and
then having to give them to nature preserves
when they get too big.
Because no matter how much you train them,
at some point their primal instinct will kick
in and they could kill a bunch of people.
Question 7 - Andrew Jones asks Why would Theon
think Yara showing up was a trick?
That’s just how brainwashed he is.
We saw a lot of the torture during season
3, but Ramsay is still psychologically abusing
him.
So the Reek persona has taken over.
It’s not a split personality like Golum
on Lord of The Rings, there aren’t two separate
identities living inside him.
He’s just completely this Reek person that
lives as an appendage of Ramsay now.
He probably didn’t even realize who Yara
was, all he saw was someone coming to kidnap
him.
Question 8 - Jaime Quirkle asks How could
Jaime become lord of Casterly Rock so quickly?
You’re asking about the practical aspects
of going from the Kingsguard to being a regular
Lord again.
Normally taking the oath of the Kingsguard
is a lifelong thing, just like taking the
Black.
But because Tywin Lannister is the Hand of
the King and the most powerful man in Westeros,
he does whatever he wants.
So they’re just sweeping a lot of the traditional
rules under the Rug.
I also saw a lot of you ask me for my opinion
on whether or not Jaime would have gone through
with it.
And yes, if Tyrion had not messed with the
plan by demanding trial by combat, Jaime would
have gone back to Casterly Rock.
He still loves Cersei deep down, but it seems
like their sexual relationship is over.
Question 9 - Misti asks Does the Crown know
where the Mountain is right now?
Yes, Tywin Lannister sent him to the Riverlands
in Season 2 to just wreak havoc and cause
problems for Robb Stark’s allies, mostly
the Tullys.
He was at Harrenhaal when Arya, Hot Pie and
Jaquen H’gar were there.
But he kind of went rogue and started going
crazy all over the locals.
So Tywin hasn’t really been doing anything
with him lately.
But he does know where he is.
And the Mountain is still one of his bannermen,
so he’ll do anything Tywin tells him to
do.
It’s just that the Mountain is one of the
most evil people on the show.
I think the only reason Tywin Lannister uses
him is because he’s so effective as a weapon.
Question 10 - Robynskie asks how did Pycelle
get Sansa’s Necklace?
Whenever Littlefinger killed him and dumped
him in the boat he dropped the necklace in
with him.
And they were in the bay right near the castle.
So he would have drifted to shore eventually.
So Littlefinger meant for the authorities
to find the body, and as the Maester, it would
have fallen to Pycelle to examine the body.
Where he would have found the necklace.
and one last Bonus Question - Claudio asks
Do you know when the other books will be published?
So right now the only book that’s been officially
announced is the World of Ice and Fire.
It’s a lot of the information from the Wiki
and maps put together with a lot of cool artwork.
It’s not a novel.
That’s being released October 28th.
Winds of Winter hasn’t been announced, but
there’s been so many new excerpts released
this year it’s possible we could see that
book before the Season 5 premiere of the show.
I’m expecting that around the same time
Season 4 premiered.
So fingers crossed we get the book by Spring
2015.
Maybe even Christmas this year.
Don’t be surprised if they announce a release
date at Comic Con.
The final Song of Ice and Fire Book.
Dream of Spring?
No idea on that one, just take the amount
of time Winds of Winter took and use that
as an estimate.
So like 2018-2019.
So I think the show will probably pass the
books in Season 7.
Assuming they get 8 seasons total.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions.
I always love being able to answer your questions
directly.
Like I said, tons of extra stuff happening
this week.
So check the description for my video schedule
and subscribe to get everything.
My next bonus video will either be a history
video for The Wall or The Wildlings.
That will post Sunday before episode 7.
Right now click here for my episode 6 video
and click here to learn more about Braavos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!